JOEL SCHINDALL: Our grading
in the class is important,
but it's done a
little bit differently
from the way an ordinary
course is graded.
In an ordinary course, there's
a specific body of material,
and so you can grade
on proficiency.
Can the student solve second
order differential equations?
So you give them some second
order differential equations
on a problem set,
and if they solve it,
they get a good grade.
And if they don't solve it, they
wouldn't get as good a grade.
We're trying to teach a
way of thinking and being
innovative so we give them
exercises and presentations,
and then we grade them on the
passion of their engagement.
Some of them have better
presentation skills
than others.
We're not looking at an
absolute mark, but we're saying,
did you go outside the box?
Did you try something new?
Given where you were when
you came into this course,
did you increase your skill set
effectively and energetically?
And if you do, that's a
good grade in the course.
And we actually give many--
many students get good grades
in a course like
this, because they've
elected to take a course to
enhance their capabilities.
And that deserves a good grade.
The ones who don't
get as good a grade
are the ones who simply
haven't participated as fully.